[Musik]
hallöchen wir machen heute lasagne und
da sag' mir war so damals als
jugendliche so dieses gericht dosiert
erstes selber gemacht habe wo die
familie probiert hat ich habe mich dann
noch richtig wie der king gefühlt und
ich bin ich immer was letztes nach hause
kommen ja weil da nix mehr übrig war ich
habe jetzt ist jede zu tragen bereit er
für die polonaise aber das lässt sich
alle zutaten da kommen gleich noch mehr
aber wir machen halt erstmal die
polonaise und dafür habe ich hier
rindfleisch außerdem öl und zwiebeln
hier habe ich gestückelte tomaten aus
der dose die werden erntefrisch in die
dose getan also dass es trotzdem frisch
und aromatisch
dann haben wir hier noch lorbeerblätter
und knoblauch mainz und müllers optional
hier vorne gibt es noch tomatenmark
etwas zucker das braucht man immer wenn
man mit tomaten arbeitet und dann habe
ich die natürlich noch salz und pfeffer
so das öl habe ich jetzt in der pfanne
erhitzt aber nur auf mittlerer stufe
also geht dann nicht zu hoch mit der
hitze gibt da am besten schon mal
zwiebeln und knoblauch hinein dann wird
das angedeutet ich denke es dauert eine
halbe minute und dann kommt auch schon
das hackfleisch mit dazu und das
hackfleisch braten wir dann richtig
schön krümelig an
[Musik]
so dass mit dem fleisch dauert so
ungefähr fünf minuten würde ich jetzt
mal schätzen
sobald das hat vielleicht gar ist einmal
das tomatenmark einarbeiten und danach
gehen wir auch schon alle anderen
zutaten die nation das gute ist falls
ihr jetzt noch gemüsereste habt dann
können sie die kleinen stimmen unterreit
rum
[Musik]
jetzt lasse ich die bolognese zugedeckt
zehn minuten lang köcheln und kümmere
mich in der zwischenzeit um die becher
mails oder zeigt er sieht aber eher
solche zutaten für mich gehört immer
besser in die lasagne ich finde es gibt
noch mal extra geschmack und ist einfach
köstlich daher machen wir das jetzt ich
meine zuallererst eine mehlschwitze und
dafür gebe ich butter in meinem kopf
ganz wichtig nicht so hoch die hitze
einstellen und verbrennt euch die butter
und wir müssen wieder von vorne anfangen
also einfach die butter rhein geben und
auf mittlerer stufe erhitzen
sobald die mutter geschmolzen ist gibt
die in einem schwung das mit dazu so
die butter masse schäumt gleich kann es
noch mal zeigen und da geben wir zu
einem dünnen strahl die milch mit dazu
und dabei immer umgehen
[Musik]
ok team welches eingearbeitet stimmchen
frei und jetzt fehlen noch vier zutaten
und zwar habe ich hier parmesan nimmt da
am besten den dänen ihr selber schreibt
das ist zwar lecker dann habe ich hier
etwas muskatnuss davon brauchen wir nur
eine prise wäre das jetzt gar nicht
möchte oder nicht da hat dann lass das
weg aber in welcher also so gehört
einfach ein bisschen muskatnuss und
natürlich etwas salz und pfeffer es gebe
ich jetzt hier noch rainer schmitz und
alles in der rest hitze und dann ist die
becher es auch schon fertig
[Musik]
aber jetzt müssen wir eigentlich nur
noch alles schichten und da könnt ihr
vorgehen die ihr möchte wichtig ist dass
auf den boden oder auflaufform etwas
flüssiges kommt also nicht direkt die
sander platten sondern ich nehme die
bolognese und falls wirklich blutige
anfänger zu gucken dann denkt bitte
daran dass ich die lorbeerblätter zum
beispiel du dass ihr die lage wird auf
jeden fall raus nimmt dann hat sie nehme
ich am ende jemand auf dem teller und
dann oh
ja
du bekommst mal karl amon okay jetzt
richtig das ganze ich mache das übrigens
so dass sich nicht nur on top gouda käse
gebe sondern auch ab und zu bei
vielleicht zweimal in die
zwischenschichten und ganz am ende
nämlich noch creme fraiche also ganz
normales creme fraiche um gewürzt gibt
es noch darüber und dann schließlich das
ganze mit käse ab ich liebe dich für
diese worte
[Musik]
so meine lieben der ofen des vorgeheizt
auf 180 grad ober und unterhitze und das
schiebe ich die lasagne jetzt rein
unteres drittel 35 bis 40 minuten ihr
werdet sehen wenn es goldbraun ist meine
schwester ist gerade da dies wird von
der schule gekommen und danach mit
verspricht sich noch einmal die tür auf
und ab damit
sich die tür
wie jetzt bleibt mir nur noch zu sagen
mach dir langsam hier unbedingt nach und
genießt es einfach ich liebe lassen ich
könnte sagen jede woche essen mit
genauso vielen tag lang sein hier ist
einfach spaß es gibt ich habe euch die
genauen mengenangaben übrigens wie immer
hier unten in die video beschreibung
geschrieben haarfein genau dann könnt
ihr euch einfach ein screenshot machen
und dann ab zum nächsten supermarkt
leute schreiben kannst du willst etwas
finden was machen wieso ich sag mal hast
das ist jetzt nicht wirklich was hättest
du nicht jeder tante ist schon reicht
ja wenn manch macht dann macht man das
war das wort zum heutigen tag wenn man
macht dann macht man also macht ja
durchschnittlicher machst du einfach
sicher es ist echt so ist echt so also
einen guten appetit und bis zum nächsten
mal auf einem kanal gießen
[Musik]